make sure that he is up to date with all
the stuff and we don't see yoshimitsu a
lot especially with someone like
complain he's been playing for years and
years and years with this character as
well but he's going up against one of
the best players in the world in md
luffy let's go
so it's gonna be very interesting to see
okay nice guess that's gonna be a
guaranteed stab you cannot break that um
okay yola it's gonna take him to the
wall okay just strap the wall oh in the
back you don't want to get it in the
back
yeah definitely not
all right so luffy hasn't been allowed
to do anything right now going for the
spin to win yeah oh that this is all
guaranteed
oh
i really like that you went for the
defense there because the wall but no
this is gonna be the round but it was
great awareness there from um
from luffy to go for the difference
because you know getting back turned um
splat into the wall but
yeah and he went for the back one two
and then that's a great duck from
complaints showing that he's on point he
knows the matchup yeah he's ready to
head to win this tournament man he's on
point he's here for the winners
semi-finals uh don't know why he threw
out that back one too but leave him just
testing you know it's first of two it
was the first round see what he can get
away with and right now just poking away
oh those are standing free
okay i like the space in there waiting
for his opportunity and nice
punish with the book knee
yeah okay again
oh see now with that you kind of need to
wake up or you shoot you can keep doing
that again and again and again and it
will hit because of the flip over
okay resources have been spent go for
the load no we tried to go through a big
combo there should have gone for the
down two there
and he's dead well i think that the demo
man would have been enough damage to
kill but luffy went for a bit of a
bigger combo didn't work out from
complaining up two rounds now yeah
you're right i forgot yeah demo man does
hit there okay does the demo man there
gets the side kind of moves flat
yep
okay nice sweet
okay big combo i love it okay man so on
point complain right now jesus showing
his yoshi knowledge but lovely hopkins
put him into that he's just gonna get
the wall
sidewalk goes to the town
i say nice
i don't know what he hit but it was nice
and what the hell hi okay it must be the
boots man cowboy hit the tentacle let's
just say that
they hit a hidden tentacle in it
the invisible tentacles
what a conversion there from complaints
oh boy oh boy oh that's gonna be it nice
complain with the first match and
there's gonna be there's gonna need to
be some serious adaptation done here
from luffy because i mean even though he
got around complain looked comfortable
and that those combos the oaky
everything one point yeah even that
conversion when it was like weird it
looked like he kind of went to the side
and behind him and he still managed to
get the combo off of that and maximum
conversion that's that's how you know
he's a character specialist when you're
converting stuff like that where you're
you're on the right side and you go to
the left side behind him on the wall
splat and you still game off the wall to
get a tailspin
man
you are you're a character specialist at
that point for sure and
there's a lot of things that i know
complain hasn't even done yet like he
has a lot more tricks up them sleeves
you know because i've played him i've
seen him play as well a lot and i just
know for a fact with all the stuff that
yoshi did there's a few things that
yoshi got in this new season that that
if if he gets put onto the back foot
there's things he can bring out we
haven't even seen him use the flash yet
you know what i mean
complain is in a great position because
his first or two and he hasn't even used
a fraction of what he's capable of doing
with yoshi so now i think luffy has to
do a lot of adaptation work here yes
definitely a lot of adaptation well he
was promising he seemed like the he lost
the first round he was in control of
that with a back one two like he said
but probably testing on the walls
probably shouldn't have done that
probably just you know committed to a
back one see if he reacts like a twitch
doc and then you know okay this guy's on
point you know he's looking for that
he's ready he's seen it he kind of just
put it out as a commitment
unfortunately there was docked and lost
the round that could have been two
rounds a piece and it could be fine for
the final round so i don't think it was
too far gone from luffy you can
definitely make the comebacks what i'm
trying to say yeah yeah okay winners
semi-finals here one oh jungle outpost
uh again it's gonna it's a good stage to
go to because of course with paul having
the breakable balcony and the breakable
wall um it allows him to get some pretty
serious damage if you can get get there
but let's see man serious adaptation
needs to be done here from luffy hey
okay he went for that unconventional
punishment on the low there just you
know caught him in the headlights he's
watching yeah
he uses that power crush how far are we
going okay
yeah
oh a nice bit it doesn't really
capitalize off of it
okay a little bit of that spacing game
now okay get the punish
he's fishing for that downfall too
that's one of the additions that moosh
you got in this game i remember i think
all the tekken iterations that down four
two did not launch like that
yeah nice oh boy
please be very careful she does have
rage nice high
stash out of the
destroy the sword sweep
yeah that you've got to be very careful
there when yoshi has drained because his
rage drive is like 40 i think 14 frames
oh it's very quick and it high crashes
too so you know good stuff then luffy
with the patience yeah just wait um um
complain just to basically kill himself
you know you can't do that as well but
you know in an unconventional way he
killed himself
okay
to make sure he's not stepping out the
wall just oh that was sick ninja's out
of there okay no small stomps we haven't
seen that's the first time i went for a
flash there
yeah luffy was probably not
probably wasn't expecting it he was
backing out
i'm loving this with luffy a lot more
patience now bob you can see right yeah
well i guess now he has to be he um
complains showing him the flashlight i
guess you have to oh
as i said before the match that crash
has three plus four what are you doing
oh my god this guy's trying to start on
him he's like now i'm going to go for
the big what instant whilst i need three
he doesn't have to do it but he's trying
to do it anyway two rounds up now
adaptations being made and then again
you saw it there going for the crash
three plus four he's going for the flash
punish now the thing is is very it's
inconsistent you saw it hit last round
but that time it didn't it really
depends on like the angle and the
distance he does it from the wall
there's a lot of to go into that
yeah for sure nice side step down for
two it's gonna get blocked complain now
putting on some pressure nice get the
flip hole back oh we running the yeah
that should reach the wall yeah that's
gonna be nice nice complaint on the
board this is good like you know
sometimes people forget man don't tech
roll versus yoshi man in certain
situations but it's even hard because
now he's got that uh is it crash that's
one that hits grounded so it's like a
mix-up game in itself oh that was
unfortunate i thought he had the correct
read there but
you know he read the wrong book like
what was that he read the wrong book he
had to write read but you know he read
the wrong book for his homework
but he did read it let's just say that
that is he gonna get the yo yo yo
that was a conversion and a half a down
four two raw
yeah i love it he caught himself step
into buttons
and he's gonna go to the wall okay no
okay it has no oh just sweeps him again
he's gonna get a full conversion out of
that complain working his way back two
rounds a piece
yeah we're on set point now [ __ ]
playing to move into winners finals here
guys and put luffy into the loser
bracket can luffy bring it back okay
that hit kind of weird there nice nice
making the reading he knows that when
complaining blocks the lows he wants to
go for that sword sweep
that was sick yeah let's put the throw
break
oh you need to be very careful showing
that complaint complaining showing that
he's trying to use a flash for a
pressure alleviation
careful careful careful not punish
did he try to crack cancel um defense
there i don't know
oh god punish complain now go to the
sword sweep be careful and okay this is
scary
with a lovely comeback in the final
round 2-0 over luffy that was a that was
a bit of a heartbreaker i want to go
back because he blocked the low